welcome witches I'm your hi hostess
Liana Galera and this is the witches
council et's spellbinding series that's
completely devoted to the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina in each episode
I'll be breaking down the biggest
questions and topics from season one of
the dark netflix drama while also
bringing you exclusive answers and
interviews from Brina herself Kiernan
Shipka and the rest of the enchanting
cast but today I'm feeling fierce
because we're talking all about
everyone's favorite feline Salem in the
original Sabrina the Teenage Witch and
yes I'm talking about the Archie comics
series and the Melissa Joan Hart TV show
Salem Saberhagen was once a warlock who
was turned into a cat as punishment by
the magic realms witches Council for
plotting to take over the world
it would have been glorious me is the
firm but just emperor of Earth trust me
being a house pet wasn't even plan B but
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina have
added a few new fur raising twists when
it comes to the mythology of this
ferocious character the first is that
every young witch in the Church of night
must choose a familiar to act as her
magical companion and protector before
her dark baptism but what exactly is a
familiar well according to aunt Zelda
familiars or goblins who have taken on
the shape of animals better served at
witch masters there's nothing human
about them rather than just selecting a
familiar from a catalog Sabrina cast a
summoning spell and Salem answered her
call
and woods
okay what's your but here's the biggest
change in chilling Salem doesn't speak
well at least not as much as we're used
to did the cat just talk yes and get
this stupid hat off my head Oh No Gooden
what was it like for you when you
discovered that there's a little twist
on Salem that really only Sabrina can
hear him okay what you how am I get
through the maze to the tree yeah I mean
I like I said I I know the original
Salem is like a meme because he's so
sassy and fun and I just feel like
that's probably its own iconic thing and
it's cool that we're doing something
that's sort of slightly more different
because I don't think you could compare
to that at all so I was I was happy that
it just it felt very in line with the
show yeah to to be a little more sort of
like subtle but still sort of there it
felt like just kind of the right balance
and I mean all three of them are stars
they are always I love the fact that
there are actually three kitties who
play Salem on the series and I
completely agree with Kiernan I do think
that it's cool that the creators have
switched things up for Salem who's this
little guy straight taking him home as
for the other familiars lurking or
should I say crawling in the Spellman
household well let's just say that these
witches are having a lot of off-screen
issues with their on-screen companions
Lucy your characters familiar our
spiders yes ma'am how do you feel about
spiders realize that nothing favorite I
I don't I'm not scared of spiders it's
fine I haven't yet had to do a scene
with them on me I don't know how I would
feel about that I don't want them
crawling on me have you guys had to
conquer any of your own fears well
filled me in the show
so much for me although I heard my
familiar maybe a snake and I'm really
not down with snakes they're not my
favorite and I had a pretty allergic to
catch and then I should have told him
was scared of sweet puppies
okay that's amazing the fact that
Kiernan is actually allergic to cats
and yet nuzzles up to salem on the
series so often that just makes me adore
her even more i really thought of you as
a cat person but okay i hope you've
enjoyed this episode of the witches
council and hit that subscribe button
and check back with me for more episodes
about sabrina season one journey
featuring exclusive interviews from the
chilling cast and if you're a Riverdale
fan don't miss new episodes of my other
series Sweetwater secrets every
Wednesday and Thursday on e t--'s
youtube channel but for now hop on the
nearest broomstick and fly over to the
Comets and bewitched me with your
spellbinding thoughts do you wish that
salem talked or do you like the fact
that he's more of the strong and silent
type
which animal would you want as your
familiar and who else thinks that the
spellman ladies are oh so fierce for
conquering their fears
thanks for summoning me and I'll see you
soon witches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]